there is nothing to do but be patient
the first medical facilities albeit
rudimentary available to these West
Mosul refugees after months of conflict
these are a generation of children who
have grown up under Islamic state oh my
goodness - Baba a child ever else Allah
oh Allah oh Allah oh Allah here gas
rallies are the psychological trauma is
a key concern for camp commander whisker
Abbott have sold one yo-yo naked
linoleic and and followed that bo-gyung
Bacardi no Hickock la mancha quick ego
delayed as well
city naked oh how are you a lot like
what Allah like but I've come to meet
the global head of UNICEF sing for
himself the temporary tented classrooms
returning to education quickly he says
is key when you hear stories of young
children who have witnessed multiple
beheadings in Mosul how do you feel it
breaks my heart it breaks my heart and
it reminds me of a wonderful phrase I
once heard and that is that what we have
to do is provide children with the quiet
miracle of a normal life this camp was
only opened on the 6th of March and
within nine days it was already
completely full eleven thousand people
here and well over half of them are
children the 17 refugee camps around
Mosul are all straining our estimates of
how many people are going to be leaving
Western Mosul are now higher than they
were a month or two ago so it's a race
against time and we're doing
very bad in eastern Mosul it is the job
of the children to collect water for
their families provision of a basic need
to encourage people back home after
years of ruled by Islamic state awkward
whose uncle was taken and is still
missing tells me for these children and
those still in the camps the quiet
miracle of a normal life is to be away
from conflict and safe